[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
why mom tonight we're drinking some red
wine and a mini bottle that's really
fancy because it has a twig tied onto it
and there was a comment on a previous
video asking what's the worst parenting
advice I've ever gotten and that's
pretty funny so I figured I'll tell you
guys the three worst pieces of parenting
advice I've ever gotten in my life so
let's go right into it after a sip first
sleep when the baby's sleeping and I
know so many moms get this piece of
advice and it just makes no sense should
I do laundry when the baby's doing
laundry should I pee when the baby's
pink should I do dishes when the baby's
doing dishes I'll just like take a long
nap while the baby's sleeping and do the
rest while they're helping me out with
it because that that works out just
great when the baby is sleeping is what
I like to call get [ __ ] done time that's
when I do everything I couldn't do with
a baby in my arms try to vacuuming with
the baby in your arms and they're scared
of the vacuum they're not cooperative
people so instead of sleep when the baby
sleeps how about you volunteer to come
clean while the mommy sleeps I think
that's a better piece of parenting
advice next I had told all the time that
holding your child too much will spoil
them I don't think it's possible for
your child to get spoiled off of
physical contact I'm pretty sure the
only thing that's gonna spoil them is
giving them too much stuff that's
undeserved and letting them get away
with being a jerk without consequences
the whole point of a parent is to care
for and comfort your child so if I'm not
picking them up when they want to be
held what am I here for me picking up my
child when they're hurt or sad or
feeling bad is only gonna make them feel
more secure with themselves and
therefore being a better person and I
feel like this advice comes from a time
when parents were a lot more distant
from their kids and it was kind of like
I don't want to deal with that and now
we're in a time where parents want to
deal with that I want to be there for my
children I want to be their source of
comfort so to give me that advice is
nonsensical and last people say that you
should teach your kids to use non
anatomical words for their private parts
stating you should make up like a more
kid-friendly word for it like oh my gosh
I hurt my way we like that's just super
weird
daughter got sent home from school with
a note asking her to stop telling her
daughter to say vagina and instead to
say down there and that's just so weird
because to me down there means anything
from the weights down so like when I say
down there I can be in like legs shins
feet toes but when you use the actual
word about it it clears up all the
mystery it's not this boring thing that
you can't see the actual wart like
Voldemort everyone in Harry Potter's
like but when you actually see it it's
like oh that's who he is that being said
I was raised with the idea of not saying
anatomically correct words and to this
day I get extremely uncomfortable using
the words penis
don't I'm gonna teach my kids the
correct way to say their privates that's
just how it's gonna be that's all I got
for today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood wine mom and if you've
received a worst piece of parenting
advice leave it in the comments because
I got to see it and in the meantime I
gotta get on Facebook and start telling
other people how to raise their kids
because it's really important to do that
as a parent until next time asked what's
the worst pair of huh huh what I try to
talk fast doesn't work when I'm drinking
wine
[Music]